gatineau le 21 septembre 2018 tommy
girard se souvient très bien du passage
de la puissante tornade dans son
quartier ils pensent tous sont attirés
par sa case ont calculé par la tornade
une fois dans le cas où il y avait des
maisons que la devanture entière était
attaché il devenait poteau de l'ex
traversée dans le chemin
en moyenne on compte sept tornades par
année au québec une soixantaine au pays
certains orages violents peuvent générer
des tornades lorsque les conditions sont
réunies ici en plus la convection ya une
rotation dont guillaume devade
différentes directions différentes
forces à cet endroit là et va s'en
vendre un mouvement de rotation qui va
s'élever vers le ciel et là on aura donc
la tornade un tourbillon qui marque les
esprits et qui fascine les passionnés de
phénomènes extrêmes
mathieu lussier et père de famille
camionneurs pompiers auxiliaires et
chasseurs de tempête
forcément vu que la chasse moi et pas
pour les images radar les hommes c'est
notre coin sans compter sa propre
station météo y sont fidèles appareils
photo des orages violents
il en a vu jusque dans la célèbre allée
des tornades aux états unis se voit les
débris qui lève mathieu est conscient
que ce qui est une passion pour lui peut
représenter une source de traumatisme
pour ceux qui le subissent
mais encore aujourd'hui qu'à une
banderole le 5e jeu complètement l'aise
comme perdu confiance en infrastructures
ici julie et mon radio canada montréal